[Music]
hi mystery recap here today i'm going to
explain an action science fiction film
called bad land road to fury
spoilers ahead
watch out and take care
[Music]
at the beginning of the movie we see a
large barren land a young man named
jerome holm narrates to us that he
hasn't seen this land when it was green
but his father has
years ago it used to be home to several
farmers who grew wheat and grains on it
however after drought struck the land
not a single plant has been able to grow
most of the farmers left the place but
jerome's father ernest hoped the land
would be green again he still believes
that it just needs some water but in
this world people kill each other for
water in the first scene we see two
muggers trying to break into a tiny
house earnest catches them and kills the
first one the second mugger tries to
convince him to spare his life but is
killed when he secretly takes a gun out
his son jerome insists he could have
helped him
the house the muggers were breaking into
has an old water pump that stops working
when ernest tries to use it with no
water left the father and son make their
way on a mule to the watermen people who
extract water from deep wells through a
government deal ernest exchanges supply
with those people for water he has been
trying to convince them to provide him
with water to cultivate a small part of
his land for years
however the watermen only do it for the
right amount of money that ernest cannot
afford on their way back their mule
falls down and breaks its leg earnest
reluctantly shoots the animal dead
the two come back home to jerome's
sister mary serving them bag food
because of water scarcity we see mary
cleansing the dishes with soil the
following day jerome and ernest visits
sam levers auction house to get
something to replace the mule who died
there a robotic carrier machine called
simulate shadow sim catches their eyes
ernest wins the auction against a man
named flem lever who also happens to be
samsung
phlegm is having an affair with mary
unknown to ernest and jerome
the two then go to meet jerome's sick
mother catherine holm
she lives in a nearby hospital where she
can walk while wired to a special frame
since the frame is too expensive they
cannot bring her home
jerome spends his time with his mother
that day ernest and catherine kiss
goodbye and separate on their way back
ernest and jerome stop at a gas station
we see ernest take a gulp of petrol
after pumping it into his vehicle
the two encounter a couple with a young
baby begging for water the father robbie
wants to sell the baby because they
cannot afford to take care of him but
ernest advises against it and tells him
that he'll help them with water
robbie knows of phlegm and mary's affair
and hints earnest towards it at home
earnest confronts mary about her
sneaking out frequently but she claims
that it is her freedom and tells her
father that she hates him she tries
running away but ernest locks her in her
room and nails her window shot one
morning ernest and jerome wake up and
notice that their robot sim is missing
from its shed someone had stolen it
ernest assumes it was fleming goes to
his house but finds out from sam that he
has left with a truck that morning for
the mountains
earnest then goes looking for him to the
watermen but they knock him unconscious
when he regains consciousness it is
already night the watermen accuse him of
stealing their supplies
ernest insists that he didn't steal them
but their leader caleb attacks him
they fight for a while but ernest
manages to get his hands on his rifle
and run away from there on his way back
home he discovers flam sleeping on the
road with sim by his side it is clear
that he had stolen the machine and the
waterman's supplies ernest points the
rifle at him holds him hostage then ties
him to the machine
he wants to take flem back to the
waterman to prove his innocence on their
way flem makes comments about mary which
angers ernest
after walking for a while both of them
get thirsty flynn persuades ernest to
use the water from the waterman's supply
the two sit down to drink water and chat
flynn then tries to convince earnest to
let him go and they can share the money
but ernest is adamant about getting him
caught ernest is weak and limp he
clearly cannot walk another mile to the
waterman flynn knows this so he strikes
ernest with a stone making him hit his
head on a cliff
his head starts to bleed uncontrollably
and is not unconscious ernest wakes up
to him being tied instead of phlegm
flem pours water into ernest's mouth as
he screams
later we see phlegm arrive at ernest's
house and his motorbike to take mary she
happily runs out to him earnest still
hasn't been home so jerome goes out to
look for him he finds the machine alone
on the way
when he reaches the watermen they inform
him of earnest death
everyone assumes that it was caused by
the machine
in the following scene we see everyone
mourning earnest death at his funeral
later catherine and the kids cry in her
hospital bed
when they come out flem picks them up in
his truck
after ernest's death phlegm has now
become the mentor of the family he calms
jerome down as he hits him for killing
his father
later he tells him that mary is pregnant
with his child and that he loves her
jerome accepts their relationship
later that day phlegm goes to the
watermen and talks to them about sending
water to ernest land
caleb laughs at his idea but gets
defensive when flem blames him for
earnest death
phlegm also shows him a knife with
caleb's name that was found with earnest
body scared to be accused caleb agrees
to divert water to their field
everyone is happy when the land gets its
first sprinkle of water phlegm works day
and night to grow wheat on the land
a few months later they are fully grown
flem gets married to mary and currently
lives at earnest home with jerome and
mary
one day his father sam with some men
from the bank approaches their house
threatening to take the land because of
ernest's death
the debt is too much for phlegm to pay
so he takes the machine with him and
approaches his friend robbie that night
he knows about robbie's intention to
sell his child so he persuades robbie to
come with him just to see how much a
baby can be worth
however when they reach there robbie
realizes that phlegm has secretly made a
deal with the people to sell his baby
the people try to take the baby away
robbie resists it and is shot dead by
flat
this causes a shootout between the
dealers and flynn runs away with the
money however the robot sim is shot and
damaged this activates the auto mode in
the machine which causes it to return
back to its manufacturer calvin hoyman
the following day flynn pays the bank
from the money he sold the child with
jerome assumes that the money came by
selling sim so no one suspects anything
in the following scene we see sim
limping its way back to calvin who lives
across the border kelvin calls the
number inscribed on sim and reaches
holmes residence he talks to jerome
about the machine coming back to him
which shocks jerome because flem had
told him he sold it to robbie
jerome asks flem if robbie sold sims
parts and it's somehow made to the owner
but flem gets annoyed at him for the
question and dismisses it then he tells
them he is going to meet his mother that
evening but instead he plans to cross
the border to meet calvin the
manufacturer of sim
later he reaches the border but the
guard stops him because he is too young
to cross it a girl named anna calls him
over and tells him she knows a way he
can go to the other side
in exchange for money she puts him in a
vehicle with chickens and sends him over
they meet again at the other side and
separate jerome then goes to meet calvin
there calvin shows him all the functions
of the machine
he also shows that the machine's eyes
are cameras that were made to capture
the slope for reforestation the camera
has captured all that the machine has
seen
jerome plays the recordings and sees his
time with earnest
as he goes through it he is horrified to
see that phlegm was the one who killed
ernest
that day after ernest had gained
consciousness phlegm tied him to the
machine and set its destination to the
waterman the machine had dragged and
injured but alive earnest to his death
by the end of the video tears roll down
jerome's eyes in the evening he returns
home but doesn't confront flem about
anything
one day phlegm and jerome are hunting
deers after which jerome keeps the rifle
with him hiding it under his bed for the
future
at breakfast jerome tells phlegm about
robbie calling him
phlegm is surprised and accuses jerome
of lying because he knows robbie is
already dead
later phlegm receives a letter written
by jerome as robbie the letter asks flem
to meet robbie at the same place he has
killed earnest he is confused by this
but he decides to find out whether roby
is still alive
later at night flynn tells a pregnant
mary that he has to go out to sell
something
mary wishes him luck and asks him to
come back soon
when phlegm reaches the place he calls
for robbie as he walks he falls down a
pit and breaks his legs
he lies they're calling for help when
jerome appears in front of him
seeing him there phlegm takes a sigh of
relief and asks him for help
however jerome stands there with a rock
in his hand
phlegm realizes that he knows everything
that happened and apologizes to him
claiming it was just an accident
he begs him to spare his life for mary
and their child but jerome doesn't
listen he points the rifle at phlegm and
shoots him dead it has been two days
since the event
mary is worried about her husband but
jerome asks her to wait a little more
he has decided to keep mary in the dark
about both earnest and flems death mary
suggests they bring their mother home
because they now have the money to
afford the ringing system she lives in
the movie ends as jerome erases all the
video memory from sim
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching